it's such a huge question I mean I
really literally could could talk all
day and barely scratch the surface and I
think it would interest as many as four
or five other people how that works I
will say that it's always about tone and
if the tone is not there then there is
no there is no writing and so to get
anything done I need a tone and I need
some sense of outline and the outline is
usually much easier to get to the tone I
don't have the heart to try to make an
outline until I believe that there is a
piece of writing to be done and the
piece of writing will exist as soon as I
believe that there's a tone to write it
in so I made the mistake this fall of
spending a lot of time trying to outline
a piece I wrote about in New York State
I thought I'd come up with the tone but
I hadn't looked at those pages when I
went ahead and spent a lot of time not
only making an outline but doing
research based on that outline and then
went back and the pages were horrid just
terrible and I hated them and I hated
the person who wrote them I mean I'm in
a relatively luxurious position at this
point in my writing life where I don't
have to do things that aren't
interesting and something a piece of
writing is not interesting or worth
doing if there's not some personal risk
if there is not if it's not dangerous in
some fashion whether you're exposing
some part of yourself you'd rather not
talk about or whether you're being
trying to be sincere about something
that would be much more comfortable to
be ironic about or vice versa if you're
being sarcastic or ironic about
something that people take seriously
today just some of the obvious ways in
which writing can can have an element of
risk in it there can also be some kind
of content risks you don't want to be
seen writing such and such a thing you
don't or everybody even be literally
somewhat dangerous to do for a
journalist but particularly when there's
a some element of psychological risk
there's a discomfort the first thing you
have to know is can I can I find a way
to write about this uncomfortable thing
that will not make people uncomfortable
when they read it and that distance is
always navigated by way of the pieces
tone do you like how you sound as you
write about it or do you sound like a
pompous asshole and and then you can't
immediately know that but as soon as you
start hearing oh this I could I could
read aloud and it would not kill me and
yet it might people might simultaneously
enjoy it but also be made slightly
uncomfortable about it well that's where
I want to be and that you know when you
start hearing that and you have some
paragraphs that work like that well you
can see okay well I can write the whole
thing in that voice and it will be okay
at which point it's safe to create an
outline and go on so that's that's my
process answer